what is viewed as these days as toxic
masculinity i'm sure you've been
referred to as oh yeah toxic masculinity
okay
so break that down and because
essentially
you know uh i don't i forgot who made
the analogy here but
um like in the ukraine right now mm-hmm
okay there's a war going on if you guys
aren't okay who's fighting in the war
the man the men okay
women and children like in the titanic
men you go last that's right uh women
and children you get on the boats first
you're not complaining when the men have
to go to war or when they can't go on to
the life rafts right but it's toxic
masculinity when they approach you in a
park okay so break down toxic
masculinity and why it may not even be a
thing it's just masculinity yeah toxic
masculinity is a first world problem um
you will find that the the poorer a
nation is
the more closely they align with
traditional gender roles um
the the united states of america is one
of the richest countries in the world
one of the most powerful countries in
the world we have done we have done such
a fantastic job civilizing the world
that there are actually women in the
world who believe that they do not need
men um there was a show i think on
netflix called y as in the the letter y
as in y chromosome all of a sudden the
men disappeared i could i could not
believe that i actually saw this uh the
power grid shut down the sewer system
shut down uh things of that nature now
i'm not saying that men are superior to
women no men and women
are men and women equal that's the wrong
question men and women are different
things that we bring to the table women
generally do not and vice versa men and
women are better together so when it
comes to toxic masculinity and you'll
see in one of the skits that we play
that you guys play on our on our tick
tock when it comes to toxic masculinity
toxic masculinity is only used as a
convenience we want you to be we want
traditional masculine roles when it
suits us but then when it doesn't suit
us then we want to call you toxically
masculine there's another there's
another definition of toxic masculinity
as far as uh and women like to say this
men can't be emotional they they try to
like say okay well if guys can't show
their emotions if guys can't be
vulnerable then that's toxic to them and
it's damaging their mental health that
might be true to a point but any woman
who is around a man who is constantly
showing vulnerability showing his
emotions
showing you know his feelings and
prioritizing them is not going to be
attractive to a woman
so these women are almost like
encouraging men to become even less
attracted to them
not all and and it's funny on the back
end then we have women like janita
wondering why why are men not planning
dates it's just like devin said
masculinity is literally being
legislated out of today's men so until
that changes you're gonna have to be the
one to plan these days i'm not playing
[ __ ]
you're just triggered
here we go i'm not playing this [ __ ]
unless i ask you out okay now then i
plan and i pay and i'm your idea you're
done
whatever how often do women ask men out
percentage-wise would you guess at the
end of the day probably maybe ten
percent uh negative four percent
negative women do not do that that's
absolutely no
i've had women ask me out like i met a
woman you know what no no you're right
um women have had to start asking guys
out because when guys ask women out they
get hit with harassment suits and things
of that nature yeah but there's i feel
like there's a spectrum there okay like
i live in south beach i i'm in the bars
i'm in the clubs anyone who knows me and
miami knows i'm out there uh-huh and i'm
very respectful and i like banter and i
hey ladies how are we doing and it's in
a very gentlemanly fashion right if you
come correct there's no lawsuits coming
your way you're what if you're a creep
and women got a creep radar yes like you
know like there's gaydar or whatever gay
guys got that i don't know about that
but women have a creep radar and they'll
be like this guy's [ __ ] creepy okay
but it depends it depends on how
attractive he is thank you because i was
just gonna say that you're [ __ ] ugly
there you go okay that's really that's
really what this is it's an excuse
you're harassing me that means you agree
right i'm not attracted to you it's
interesting i don't know if you i don't
know what the percentages are but the
they say the worst doctors are the best
that are the best people
as far as malpractice lawsuits are
concerned the doctors get that get sued
the most for malpractice are doctors who
have terrible bedside manner they
they're just [ __ ] they could be the
world's greatest thoracic surgeon but if
he's an [ __ ] he's more susceptible to
a lawsuit well it's the same thing with
unattractive guys you can have two men
walk up to the same woman using
identical lines and all this other kind
of stuff the guy who's not attractive
enough is going to be looked at as a
creep the guy who's attractive all that
isn't that sweet he's stammering and
it's literally the same thing hey um i
noticed you from across the room and i
was wondering if i could get your number
if you're adam sosnick then she's like
oh how sweet blah blah blah blah blah
yeah but if you're like donovan sharp
five years ago she's like uh yeah so if
you like that clip click right here to
watch another or if you want to watch
the entire sauce cast click right here
[Music]